[Música]
nuevo escándalo por vacunaciones de
privilegio contra el hobbit 19 en
américa del sur
primero fue perú con su vacuna gate y
ahora es argentina con sus vacunas vía
ipi lo que llevó a la dimisión del
ministro de salud tras conocerse que
varias personas cercanas al gobierno si
no curaron antes del inicio de la
campaña de inmunización
en rusia el tribunal de moscú rechazó la
apelación a la sentencia del líder
opositor alexéi navalni y ratificó la
pena suspendida de 3.5 años de prisión
un juicio calificado de arbitrario por
el tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
sin embargo la justicia aportó su
condena original por el tiempo que ya
había pasado bajo arresto domiciliario
eeuu de vuelta al multilateralismo un
drástico giro después de la america
first el ex presidente de trump el
mandatario joe biden respaldó su apoyo a
la otan lado ms y el acuerdo nuclear con
irán el anuncio lo hizo en la
conferencia especial de seguridad de
múnich donde también su país volvió al
acuerdo climático de parís
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
entradas 24 cierro a blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos el
escándalo de las vacunaciones
irregulares en las cúpulas del poder en
américa latina no para luego de
conocerse el vacuna gay está en perú que
ha llevado a la dimisión de altos
funcionarios del gobierno se está pone
argentina el llamado vacunas vía y piqué
llevó a renunciar al ministro de salud
después de que se conocieran que algunas
personas de su entorno fueron vacunadas
en respetar los turnos establecidos
carla vizzotti será la nueva encargada
de la salud del país se sumirá el cargo
hoy sábado veamos el siguiente informe
de juán pupiales
un escándalo en medio de un momento
clave coincidiendo con los primeros días
de la vacunación para mayores de 70 años
se conoció que personas cercanas al ya
ex ministro de salud ginés gonzález
garcía han recibido un trato
privilegiado y se han saltado los turnos
para acceder al antídoto un periodista
cercano al ejecutivo destapó lo que se
ha denominado como vacunación y haití
una situación que llevó al presidente
alberto fernández a pedir la renuncia de
gonzález quien dimitió no sin antes
explicar que las personas vacunadas
pertenecían a los grupos competentes y
mencionando también una confusión
involuntaria la mentalidad sinceramente
que semejante malentendido pudiera
deslucir una gestión que dio un fuerte
impulso a la reconstrucción del sistema
de salud
gonzález garcía ya había sido el
ministro de salud a comienzos del 2000 y
estuvo en el cargo desde el comienzo de
la pandemia destacando por conseguir que
argentina se convirtiera en el primer
país de américa en usar la vacuna rusa
sputnik
según datos del jueves argentina había
administrado más de 635.000 dosis lo que
equivale al 1 41 por ciento de su
población
tras lo vivido en perú con un escándalo
de cientos de altos funcionarios
vacunados de manera privilegiada el
fantasma de una situación similar se
extiende sobre argentina aunque de
momento a diferencia de perú todo parece
indicar que en este caso el presidente
fernández no estaba al tanto de lo que
ocurría en el ministerio de salud
cambiamos la información vamos hasta
rusia donde un tribunal de moscú rechazó
en la apelación del líder de la
oposición alexéi navalni contra su
sentencia de prisión incluso cuando el
país se enfrentaba a la orden de un alto
tribunal europeo de derechos para poder
liberarlo navalny fue sentenciado a
principios de este mes por un tribunal
de primera instancia por violar los
términos de su libertad condicional
mientras se recuperaba en alemania un
envenenamiento con el agente nervioso
novi shock quiero saludar en ese momento
a nuestro corresponsal en la capital
rusa xavier colás xavier muy buen día
que supone esta confirmación de la
condena contra naval
pues supone que no haber clemencia para
alexéi navalni era una esperanza que
aunque pequeña existía en algunos
ámbitos de la oposición entre otras
cosas por lo que había ocurrido en el
pasado lo cierto es que hasta la fecha
las autoridades de julia la justicia
rusa siempre habían evitado que alexéi
navalni un carismático líder de la
disidencia rusa pasase largas temporadas
en prisión tal vez por el miedo a que su
popularidad creciese pero esta vez no ha
habido marcha atrás y aleccionaban y
parece que va a tener que pasar dos años
y medio en una prisión que todavía no se
ha determinado puesto que sigue en un
centro de detención preventiva porque
tiene todavía un juicio pendiente del
cual tendrá que responder hoy por cierto
así es ayer y le pregunto ahora entonces
qué reacciones esperan tras esta
decisión
pues lo cierto es que esta condena a
naval y que conocimos ya el pasado 2 de
febrero y ha sido la confirmación su
sitio es un momento importante es
protestas no sólo en la capital rusa y
en otras grandes ciudades como san
petersburgo sino en todo el país hubo
miles de detenidos las cifras más altas
desde el inicio de las manifestaciones
de esta disidencia en el año 2012 sin
embargo la oposición rusa decidió hace
unos días hacer una pausa en esas
manifestaciones hasta la primavera tal
vez por las bajas temperaturas que estos
días por ejemplo en la capital rusa
rondan los 20 grados bajo cero no
obstante está previsto que mediante
algún tipo de flashmob o de protesta
simbólica como ocurrió el pasado día de
san valentín el 14 de febrero la
oposición vuelva a mostrar su desacuerdo
con nuestra sentencia sobre la cual
también ha sido muy crítica otros países
incluso el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos así es xavier muchísimas gracias
por toda la información que tengo usted
un feliz resto de día y no con tanto
frío con continuamos con más información
el consejo nacional electoral
terminó el escrutinio de los votos de
las elecciones presidenciales del pasado
7 de febrero y espera difundir los
resultados oficiales el día de hoy luego
de la llegada de tres últimas actas del
extranjero con votos para la asamblea
todavía no se conoce quién será el rival
del corréis andrés hará uso en la
segunda vuelta de aller indígenas ya q
pérez o el conservador guillermo lazo
entre tanto pérez encabeza una
movilización de comunidades indígenas
que piden una revisión de los resultados
eeuu hizo oficial este viernes ante la
comunidad internacional su regreso al
multilateralismo un drástico giro
después de una administración bajo el
poder de donald trump en donde la
política era dar prioridad a la unión
americana el presidente joe biden
respaldó también su apoyo a la
organización mundial de la salud la otan
y el acuerdo nuclear con irán el mismo
día en que washington volvió al acuerdo
de parís el informe de juan piales
que es back un anuncio esperado ante un
escenario internacional y de forma
virtual desde el regreso de acuerdo de
parís hasta la reactivación del diálogo
con irán es oficial
eeuu vuelve a estrechar sus lazos con
occidente fue el mensaje de job aiden en
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich un
mensaje en recibido con alivio las cosas
van a mejor en gran manera para el
multilateralismo este año respecto a
hace dos años y eso tiene mucho que ver
con que joe biden se haya convertido en
el presidente de los eeuu de américa
día de peso en la agenda internacional
porque el margen de la conferencia de
múnich
también hubo reunión del g7 las siete
potencias que maneja
o menos de la mitad de toda la economía
mundial estos países se comprometieron a
impulsar la economía internacional en
medio de la crisis por la pandemia
también buscan asistir a las naciones en
desarrollo para que avancen en sus
planes de vacunación con una ayuda de
hasta el 5 por ciento de su actual
distribución de los antídotos creo que
si queremos lograr este multilateralismo
que produzcan resultados el desafío que
tenemos enfrente es entre
estadounidenses y europeos permitir a
todos los países del mundo pobres y
emergentes acceder de manera más rápida
posible al diagnóstico y también a las
vacunas y a mejorar su sistema de salud
pero hay un contrapeso a esta alianza ya
los desafíos con rusia puede que sean
diferentes a los de china pero son igual
de reales no se trata de poner al este
contra occidente no es que queramos un
conflicto queremos un futuro en donde
todas las naciones puedan determinar
libremente su propio camino sin una
amenaza de violencia o coerción es un
pulso que ya está en marcha
tanto moscú como beijing han aprovechado
su distribución de las vacunas para
expandirse internacionalmente
de áfrica hasta latinoamerica
evidenciando en el caso de la unión
europea un fracaso en su industria
farmacéutica y continuamos con
información de eeuu porque ya son al
menos 47 los muertos y cientos de miles
sin electricidad y servicio de agua tras
la tormenta invernal que azota a algunos
estados del país específicamente a texas
los cortes en el suministro de
electricidad en ese estado han afectado
a las estaciones de venta de combustible
y el suministro de agua potable por lo
que los texanos hicieron filas durante
horas para conseguir el líquido vital
por cuarta noche consecutiva continuaron
las protestas y disturbios callejeros en
españa' por el encarcelamiento del
rapero pablo hasél y se espera que se
produzca en concentraciones también en
madrid a lo largo de este fin de semana
el rapero catalán cumple desde el martes
una condena de nueve meses de prisión
por los delitos de enaltecimiento del
terrorismo y en injurias a la corona
ambos a tipificados por el código penal
español como delitos de expresión
[Música]
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 continúa con
nosotros buen sábado feliz día
[Música]